สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันศุกร์ค่ะ
วันศุกร์ค่ะนักเรียน
ได้ค่ะวันนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 23
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
นะคะนักเรียน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 22
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่ค่ะ
วันที่ 24
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลาบ่าย
สอง
โมงกี่นาที
32 นาทีค่ะ
บ่ายสองโมงสามสิบสองนาทีนะตอนนี้บ่ายสอง
ที่ออสเตรเลียอากาศเป็นยังไงคะร้อนหนาว
หรือว่า
ฝนตก
อากาศโอเคค่ะ
ก็หนาวนะคะนักเรียน
แต่ไม่หนาวมากหนาว
ไม่หนาวมาก
ค่ะเพราะว่า
ก้าว
องศาใช่ไหมคะแล้วฝนตกไหมคะครูฟ้าค่ะ
ฝนกำลังจะตก
ฝนยังไม่ตกค่ะแต่ว่าฝนกำลังจะตกนะคะ
ตอนนี้บ่ายสองสามสิบสองนาทีถ้าเวลา
เดินไปถึงประมาณ
15:00 น
ฝนอาจจะตกก็ได้
ใช่คิดว่านะคะอาจจะตกก็ได้แล้วครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิง
ผู้หญิงอยู่ประเทศอะไรคะอเมริกาไทย
สวิตเซอร์แลนด์สวีเดนนอร์เวย์เดนมาร์ก
ญี่ปุ่น
ใกล้ๆกันหมดเลย
ประเทศไทยอยู่ใกล้แคนาดาหรอคะ
ไม่ได้อยู่ประเทศไทยค่ะ
ผู้หญิงอยู่ที่ไหนคะ
[เพลง]
กี่โมงแล้ว
ตอนนี้เที่ยงคืนสามสิบสี่นาทีถูกไหมเนี่ย
ตอนกลางคืน
[เพลง]
ใช่ตอนกลางคืน
อากาศเป็นยังไงคะ
19 องศาค่ะ 19
แต่ว่า
19 องศา
องศาไม่ร้อนมากแต่พรุ่งนี้อ่ะพรุ่งนี้วัน
เสาร์ใช่ไหมคะพรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์ที่ 24 ครู
หญิงเนี่ย
ก็คิดคิดว่าอยากจะไปทะเล
อยากไปทะเลแต่ครูฟ้าดูอากาศวันพรุ่งนี้สิ
คะ
24 องศา 27 องศาเซลเซียสและฝนตกค่ะนัก
เรียนนักเรียนเห็นไหมคะว่าฝนตกอะไรคะผู้
หญิงให้ครูฟ้าดูไงตอนแรกคิดว่าครูฟ้าไม่
เห็นว่าฝนตก
ฝนตกตั้งแต่วันศุกร์วันเสาร์วันอาทิตย์
วันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธแล้ววันศุกร์วัน
เสาร์วันอาทิตย์เนี่ยฝนตก 70%
[เพลง]
หรอ
ไม่โอเคอ่ะค่ะ
ถ้าครูหญิงไปทะเล
ไปทะเลแล้วเจอฝน
ไม่โอเคไม่สนุก
ไงไปทะเลแล้วฝนตกตั้งแต่ 9 โมงเช้าจนถึง 6
โมงเย็นฝนตกทั้งวันก็ไม่ได้แต่
ฝนใช่ไหม
หรือว่าอากาศร้อนอันนี้ประเทศไทยถ้า
ประเทศไทยก็คงจะร้อนแล้วก็ออสเตรเลียของ
ครูฟ้า
ก็หนาว
ครูฟ้าก็ไม่ชอบหนาวผู้หญิงก็ไม่อยากให้ฝน
ตกอยู่ประเทศไทยก็ไม่อยากร้อนแต่เราทำ
อะไรไม่ได้เราควบคุมอากาศไม่ได้
[เพลง]
ควบคุมอากาศ
ใช่ก็ครูหญิงเนี่ยพรุ่งนี้จะไปทะเลใช่ไหม
คะแต่ดู
ดูที่โทรศัพท์เนี่ย
โทรศัพท์บอกว่าฝนตก 70% แล้วครูหญิงก็บอก
ท้องฟ้าก้อนเมฆ
ห้ามฝนตกนะ
ครูหญิงจะไปทะเล
ทำไม่ได้ไง
ควบคุมไม่ได้
หรอกค่ะผู้หญิง
แล้วผู้หญิงจะไป
เมื่อไหร่คะเนี่ยมันฝนตกทุกวันทำยังไงล่ะ
ใช่ก็เลยแบบพอเห็นแบบนี้ก็เลยคิด
แต่ถ้าครูหญิงหรือครูฟ้าเราเนี่ยควบคุม
อากาศได้เราวันนี้ไม่อยากให้ฝนตกก็บอกฝน
ห้ามตกนะครูฟ้าไม่อยากให้หนาวครูฟ้าก็บอก
วันนี้ไม่หนาวถ้าเราทำได้ครูฟ้าคิดว่ามัน
จะดีไหม
เอาดีสิผู้หญิง
ถ้าเราควบคุมอากาศได้ใช่ไหม
ก็ดีค่ะถ้าเราบอกครูฟ้าอยากให้ฝนตกจังเลย
ฝนตกก็โอเคครูฟ้าอยากให้ร้อน
แล้วอากาศร้อน
ก็จะซักผ้า
ใช่ไหมเพราะว่าถ้าครูหญิงอยู่ประเทศไทย
แล้วคุยหญิงเนี่ยซักผ้าอันนี้เครื่องซัก
ผ้าใช่ไหม
ซักผ้าเสร็จแล้วผู้หญิงก็ต้องตัดผ้าอย่าง
นี้
ใช่ไหม
ถ้าผู้หญิงเอาผ้าใส่เครื่องซักผ้าเดินออก
มาแล้วก็เห็น
ฝนตก
แต่ถ้าเราบอกอากาศได้ว่าห้ามฝนตกวันนี้
ฉันซักผ้าก็ดีนะ
คะ
ใช่แต่ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยบอกอากาศได้ควบคุม
อากาศได้ครูฟ้าอยากให้ใน 1 วันของครูฟ้า
เนี่ยอากาศเป็นยังไง
ร้อนหนาวฝนตก
ฟ้าอยากให้ 1 วันของครูฟ้าเนี่ยนะคะ
อากาศอะไรเนี่ย
20 องศาเซลเซียส
ทั้งวันเลยหรอคะ
ตอนเช้าอาจจะซักตั้งแต่
8 โมงเช้าใช่ไหมตอนเช้าครูฟ้าอยากให้
อากาศประมาณ 20 องศา
ประมาณ 20 องศาค่ะ
นิดหน่อยค่ะนิดหน่อยเพราะว่า
แดดตอนเช้าเนี่ยนะคะตอน 8 โมงเนี่ยนะคะ
แดดโอเค
อันนี้อะไรคะเนี่ย
แดด
เดียว
ตอน 8 โมงเช้าเนี่ยมันดีมากใช่ไหม
เราได้วิตามินไง
มันก็ไม่ร้อนมาก
8 โมงเช้าเนี่ยดีค่ะ
ครูฟ้าอยากจะให้อากาศเป็นยังไงล่ะ
ฝนตกไหม
อยากให้
ประกาศเหลือ
17 แล้วกัน
อยากให้มันเย็นขึ้นเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะ
ทำไมอ่ะ
มันเย็นขึ้นมันน่าจะโอเคเพราะว่า 17 องศา
เซลเซียสแต่บางคนก็โอเคแต่บางคนก็ไม่โอเค
ไง
เพราะมันร้อนมันหนาว
มันหนาวใช่ไหมแต่กลัวคิดว่า
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะ 17 องศาเซลเซียสเพราะว่าเรา
ไปเรียน
ไปทำงาน
มันก็โอเคอยู่แล้วให้อาการเย็นนิดนึงก็จะ
สบายขึ้นไง
จนถึง
6 โมงมั้ยตอนเย็นๆ
4 โมง 4 โมง
4 โมงเย็น
ครูฟ้าอยากให้อากาศเป็นยังไง
ลดลงอีกเหรอคะ
อยากให้อากาศลดลงอีกค่ะคุณหญิง
ทำไมอ่ะ
มันจะหนาวมากขึ้นนะ
ไม่เป็นไรกลัวพลอยชอบอากาศหนาวนะคะหนาวก็
โอเคประมาณ 15 เซลเซียส
20 เซลเซียส
แล้วถ้าเป็นตอนกลางคืนล่ะ
[เพลง]
นอนกลางคืน
อยากให้เป็นยังไง
เฮ้ยอยากให้มีฝนตก
อันนี้คือฟ้าอยู่ออสเตรเลียใช่ไหมคะแล้ว
ก็อยากให้ฝนตกตอนกลางคืน
อยากให้มีฝนตกตอนกลางคืนค่ะผู้หญิง
ทำไมอ่ะคะครูฟ้าถ้าฝนตกมันก็จะหนาวมาก
ขึ้นนะก็ใช่แหละแต่ครูฟ้าชอบเวลาฝนตกนะคะ
ก็นอนอยู่บนเตียงมีผ้าห่ม
อากาศหนาวๆ
มันจะสบายมากนะคะนักเรียน
ไม่รู้แต่ครูฟ้าชอบฝนนะหมายถึงเวลาแบบฝน
ตกเราฟังใช่ไหมฝนตก
แล้วก็นอน
หลับสบาย
ก็เหมือนกันนะถ้าคุยหญิงผู้หญิงไม่ได้
อยู่
ประเทศไทยอยู่ประเทศไทย
อีก 1 รอบนะคะประเทศไทยเนี่ยร้อนมากๆบาง
วันเนี่ย 3 อะไรคะ
ประเทศไทยแบบนี้สิคะต้องเป็นเหมือนหมา
น้อยอย่างนี้
[เพลง]
ใช่ไหมอันนั้นอะไรคะประเทศไทยหรอคะ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยบอกอากาศ
ได้ควบคุมอากาศได้ผู้หญิงจะให้ตอนกลางวัน
เนี่ยนะคะอากาศประมาณ
26 องศาแล้วก็มีลม
มีลมมากๆมีลมเยอะๆจะได้ไม่ร้อนเย็นสบาย
ถ้าผู้หญิงเนี่ยออกไปเดินหรือว่าออกไป
วิ่งโอเค
แต่ต้องมีลมนะให้มีดวงอาทิตย์เนี่ยน้อยๆ
ทำไมต้องมีลมคะ
ก็ถ้า 26 องศาแต่ลมไม่มี
มันก็ร้อนนะครูฟ้า
ถ้าเป็นประเทศไทยนะ
ถ้ามีลมเราจะรู้สึกแบบอ้อสบายถึงแม้ว่า
ถ้าอากาศจะ
30 องศาถ้ามีลมมีลมมีลมพัด
เย็นสบายนะคะแล้วก็ถ้าเป็นเวลากลางคืน
เหมือนครูฟ้าค่ะให้ฝนตก
อยากให้ฝนตกตอนกลางคืนเพราะว่าถ้าฝนตก
เนี่ย
มันจะเลอะนะคะมันจะลดลงอาจจะเหลือสัก 22
องศาเซลเซียสแล้วก็นอนแล้วก็ฝนตก
เย็นสบาย
ให้เพราะคิดว่าหลายๆคนชอบนอนนะคะ
เวลาที่ฝนตก
แต่ถ้าตอนกลางคืนถ้าพรุ่งนี้ใช่ไหมวันนี้
เนี่ยถ้าพรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์วันที่ 24 อย่าง
เงี้ยถ้ากูยังมีแพลนคิดไปทะเล
ไปทะเล
ก็จะบอกว่าวันที่ 24 เนี่ยไม่เอาห้ามฝนตก
เพราะว่าจะไปทะเลแล้วครูฟ้าล่ะครูฟ้าอยู่
ออสเตรเลียครูฟ้าอยากให้หิมะตกไหมคือ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยฝนตกมีแต่หิมะตกเนี่ย
ถ้าเราควบคุมได้ก็ครูหญิงก็อยากให้ประเทศ
ไทยมีหิมะตกนะคะ
ทำไมอ่ะผู้หญิงกูก็ไม่อยากให้ประเทศไทยมี
หิมะตกเอ้ยครูฟ้าไม่อยากให้หิมะตกเลยค่ะ
ตอนนี้ครูฟ้าอยากเห็นหิมะนะคะแต่
ไม่อยากให้เห็น
ไม่อยากให้หิมะตก
อยากให้หิมะตกใช่ไหมแล้วเราก็จะได้ปั้น
ตุ๊กตาหิมะ
หรือว่าคนภูเขาแล้วก็เล่น
สกีไหม
[เพลง]
อยากให้หิมะตกแต่ว่าให้หิมะตกไม่เอา 0
องศาเนี่ยไม่เอามะนาว
สัก 10 องศาแล้วก็หิมะตกแล้วก็ลมลมไม่มี
นะไม่เอาลมห้ามลม
[เพลง]
เยอะมาก
มีลม
ไม่เอาลงค่ะ
หนาวค่ะ
ตอนนี้
เดือนมิถุนายนที่แคนเบอร์ราหนาว
ห้ามหิมะตกที่แคนเบอร์ราไม่เอา
ม๊าอยากให้หิมะตกที่แคนเบอร์ราในเดือน
ธันวาคมในคริสต์มาสนะคะคะเดือนธันวาคม
หิมะตกโอเคนะ
มีต้นคริสต์มาสแล้วก็หิมะตก
เพราะว่าที่ออสเตรเลียเดือนธันวาคมร้อน
ครูฟ้าก็เลยอยากเปลี่ยนครูฟ้าควบคุมได้
บอกได้วันไหนหิมะตกวันไหนร้อนวันไหนฝนตก
นะคะแล้วถ้าเป็นนักเรียนล่ะคะถ้านักเรียน
ควบคุมอากาศได้บอกได้นักเรียนอยากให้วัน
นี้ของนักเรียนเป็นยังไงก็คอมเม้นคุยกับ
เราได้นะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้ครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าไปก่อนเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้า
นะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ
[เพลง]